wow
a spider guy really messed things up
i'm mobius by the way i specialize in
erasing undesirable realities in
multiverse and this clean cut peter
parker just created a whole mess of
undesirable
i mean he made branching timelines that
contain some of the most incompetent
spider-man the tva has ever seen i'll
tell you what
i'm gonna prune every last one of them
[Music]
jelly hoe
i'm gonna die
[Music]
you have a train to catch
any more fight ideas
you got a few
we're slowing down
uh
[Music]
hmm
only one timeline left to print
the worst spider-man of them all now
take on this
[Music]
what's up penis parker
hey folks hey oh look we had a blast
look at what we got this one
we had a blast like this video um
comment and subscribe check out the
corridor crew video where we break down
how we did all this crazy
um did you rehearse this at all no
there's nothing in her hair
does this look reversed i came down here
to shoot something this doesn't look
gross just hijacked ourselves yeah
you're crazy
out of here he adds so much production
value when we put him in the shots it's
true